You think that Congress
is going to get it together
in the next few months
to raise the debt ceiling
or the debt ceiling?
That's what I'm talking about.
Yes, you do.
The only question is
how close they get to it
before they do it,
because you'll feel the pain
before it happens.
How much pain,
even if we don't default, it's
if we get to the brink,
I think it's a bad idea.
And, you know, we
our government
debt could be downgraded again.
This economy is the pillar
of the world economy.
of taking care of Americans
to make it your military strong
and making sure that people want
to be part of our
or our alliances,
that you
want to be part of the American group
that tries
to keep the world safe for democracy.
Yeah, that's important.
So the closer we get to that,
the more we're
going to damage all of that.
And then you'll see it in the markets.
You'll see it, and that will
that will scare people.
I hope Washington's listening.
The position of the Biden White House
now is it
will not negotiate
with Republicans and Republicans,
many of them,
because they don't want to pass a clean
They want concessions.
So should the Biden
White House negotiate?
I think one of the great lessons
of the last 20 years
is that if you can't pass things
that bipartisan support,
you shouldn't pass it.
I mean, yes,
everyone should negotiate
to do the right thing for the country.
And I don't I don't want to get involved.
The debate about the Republicans
who want to reduce the deficit.
I kind of agree with that.
The Democrats
who would like now
to get rid of the debt ceiling crisis.
But people have torched each other
over and over.
I'd rather one day we get rid of torture
but in the meantime,
yes, I'd like to be resolved.
And when I go to Washington, all the
all the most
the people there know how serious this is
and they want to get it to resolution.
You've even heard Kevin McCarthy
talk of that.
Mitch McConnell,
you know, President Biden in his own way.
You have called out
the Biden administration
for not playing
more of a leadership role in energy
especially.
He said, look, America
should have been pumping more oil
and gas should have been supported.
This administration did disapprove
more drilling in Alaska.
Good start.
It's a good start, but it's just a start.
I mean, this is a long term
strategy to be that oil and gas
and the American public should know this.
It's not secure.
And if it's not secure and affordable,
it's bad for the climate.
All that happened
because we weren't pumping more
is that more coal is you.
It's not just in India,
Philippines, China and Indonesia,
but Germany
and Netherlands and France
turning back on their coal plants.
Safe and affordable is critical.
The transition, by the way,
the best the easiest way to do CO2
is reduce coal, gas
so therefore you need pipelines.
But we're not you know, look at us.
We're not
approving pipeline permits,
but Norway approving solar wind grid
like we're really stuck
in our own underwear in this one,
stuck in our own underwear.
We have to do a better job.
Can I ask you about a few states?
Do you guys have more employees now?
In Texas than in New York?
And you said it shouldn't
have been that way.
Why is it that way?
Texas is is completely welcoming.
So if you look at it in multiple ways,
low income taxes, low corporate taxes
and easy to get space they want.
You got the mayor's call
and they have great universities.
They now have you know,
if you look at Dallas,
they now have great arts and science.
This has become a competitive world.
When I started working, that wasn't true.
Now, as cities around the world,
they're pretty competitive.
And I think every city should say,
you know, what's the competition?
And they should be thoughtful about that.
If you have the highest individual taxes,
the highest corporate taxes,
the highest state taxes, anti-business,
you can't look at, you know, in New York
and allow Amazon
to build a great headquarters.
There was that
little more context to that.
But I understand that. But just.
But why would you try
to build in New York that you're building
a huge,
huge hole
right in the middle of New York,
doing the best buildings
the world's ever seen.
You love Florida.
In fact, a few weeks ago,
you said you were a very pro Florida.
You're growing there.
Does Governor
DeSantis punishing Disney
for taking a public stand
on social and diversity issues?
Give you pause?
Not directly, no. Really?
Because, yes,
this week Bob Iger said
that's anti-business and anti Florida.
And he said it's punishing a company
for exercising a constitutional right.
I'm not going to get involved
in all this social stuff like that.
We support the LGBT community
aggressively and actively.
And you'll still
when you talk about fight to Santos.
Yes. Okay.
I want to ask you about something
that is in the news that JP
Morgan is in the news
about a former client of yours,
and that is Jeffrey
Epstein,
Steve Morgan
Morgan's being sued now
by the US Virgin Islands.
They're alleging that your bank helped
facilitate payments, Epstein's victims
and benefited from human
trafficking while ignoring warnings.
Do those allegations have merit?
So I cannot talk about current litigation
except to say that
whenever these things come up
or we have some of the best lawyers
in the world, compliance
out of the DOJ,
out of SCC and fourth divisions
who review all of these things
and make decisions
at the time based on what they know
as best as they know,
they're going to be deposed.
We've learned
now in this case
in the spring, in retrospect.
Jamie,
do you think JPMorgan should have
acted more quickly
after Epstein
pleaded guilty
to one of these charges in 2008
because he was your client
for five more years?
Hindsight is a fabulous gift.
We're going to end on
artificial intelligence
You find it
fascinating, in your words, staggering.
The tip of the iceberg.
You guys are using chat.
What's this going to do to our economy?
It could be okay.
Or every technology
has ever been adopted,
which is good for the economy.
And, you know,
I tell people,
you go back to 1900
40 million people worked on farms
you know, technology is now
1 million people.
Are we worse off now?
39 million people now doing other things.
So the Internet, electric power,
computers, all made us better off
our GDP per person.
$70,000.
Yes. This person.
What if we get replaced?
But you won't be.
It'll just change
how you work and add things
But if it did okay,
but if it did, then society could step in
and make sure it's done
in a way that people can have jobs
and good paying jobs.
But we get the benefit from it.
It actually put about air.
There is a downside.
Bad guys are going to use it, too.
So, you know, for people like us,
we use it for all these things.
We also have to
think of risk and fraud and marketing and
errors, you know, helping clients.
We also have to use it to come back.
Combat bad guys in the cyber
world, the fake ID world
and things like that. So.
So I think it'll be a plus.
But if you do it sort exercise
2 million truckers,
if they go lose their jobs tomorrow
because of, you know, air driving,
you know,
and they're going to go from $75,000
a year to next job at 25.
That would destroy families.
I wouldn't do that.
I would phased in over
time have retraining.
So even if you could
it doesn't mean you should
even if you could
does not mean you should.
And that's where society
should step in
and government
and make sure that this helps everybody.
And then if there's soon as you get
get heard
the low end, do something about it,
analyze it, think about it,
we train reskill,
help them move or whatever to have
probably a better job.